[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous
présentent le club des
territoires et avec nous pour ce club if
trard bonjour Y merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous directeur adjoint de la
rédaction du Figaro et Mathieu souer
bonjour Mathieu merci d'être là essiste
expert associé auprès de la Fondation
Jean jores co-auteur de 2022 la FB
populiste chez plomb on va parler avec
vous de la situation ProcheOrient plus
de 2 semaines de conflit entre Israël et
le Hamas et un débat aura lieu cet
après-midi à l'Assemblée nationale que
peut-on attendre d'Élisabeth borne alors
que des positions de la France insoumis
sont contestées par le reste de
l'hémicycle le débat sera-t-il tendu on
verra ça avec vos situation
Proche-Orient qui renforce l'inquiétude
du gouvernement sur l'état de la menace
terroriste en France Gérald haranin se
montre ferme très ferme sur le sujet sur
les mesures qu'il veut rajouter dans le
projet de loi immigration pour y faire
face et mieux expulser les radicalisés
Alex hier il a donné une grande
interview au JDD on verra ça et oui le
ministre de l'Intérieur qui continue
d'envoyer des signaux à la droite pour
essayer de faire adopter ce texte
immigration Gérald Herman en fait-il
trop ce sera le second débat du club
d'abord on regarde l'actualité dans nos
régions l'actualité dans nos régions
avec nos partenaires de la presse
régionale on va à Nice retrouver Denis
carot bonjour Denis merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous directeur des
rédactions de Nice Matin Denis on va
revenir avec vous sur la dépression qui
a touché vendredi les Alpes Maritimes et
notamment la vallée de la vésubi 3 ans
après la tempête
Alex oui bonjour Arrien bonjour à tous 3
jours après le passage de la tempête
àine la situation est très contrastée
selon les secteurs et les vallées
touchées la vallée de la Roya qui avait
été très durement touchée par la tempête
Alex en octobre 2020 a été plutôt
épargné a plutôt bien résisté alors
c'est beaucoup moins le cas de la vallée
de la vésubi et notamment à Saint-Martin
où les dommages sont très importants
Christian Estrosi le président de la
métropole euh par le même ce matin dans
nos colonnes de cataclysme au Boréon le
Boréon c'est une zone qui est située au
au-dessus de Saint-Martin vzubi la
montagne est tombée tous les arbres sont
abattus nous nous explique-t-il et dans
ce secteur effectivement bah les maisons
ont résisté mais les routes ont été
dévastées et le quartier n'est désormais
plus accessible qu'à pied alors dans
cette interview à Nice ce matin
Christien estroszi répond aussi à la
colère des habitants de Saint-Martin
vezubi nos journalistes l'ont l'ont
constaté ce weekend ils sont à bout ils
ne comprennent pas que les travaux
réalisés après la tempête Alex en 2020
n'est pas tenu euh des ponts et des
routes ont été complètement détruites et
et vendredi le préfet des Alpes
Maritimes HUG Moutou a réquisitionné
cinq entreprises pour engager des
travaux d'urgence ce qui a démarré euh
des dès ce weekend et Christian estrzi
annonce d'ailleurs dans dans ni ce matin
qu'une des routes principales celle qui
relie Saint-Martin à venançon devrait
être rendu à la circulation dès demain
soir et Denis vous allez nous parler de
la visite de Christophe Béchu le
ministre de la transition écologique
oui le ministre Christophe Béchu sera là
ce matin il viendra constater la la
situation et découvrir bah les images
comme celle qui est derrière moi des des
dégâts extrêmement importants à à
Saint-Martin c'est là où il vient où il
vient ce matin il devrait annoncer des
des mesures d'urgence hein pour ce
secteur très durement touché euh qui a
vécu deux phénomènes météo exceptionnels
en 3 ans seulement les habitants
aujourd'hui veulent l'assurance qu'on ne
se contentera pas de travaux provisoires
euh et qu'on va vraiment engager des
travaux qui permettront à la vallée de
de résister sachant que tout le monde
euh est totalement conscient que des
épisodes météo comme ceux qu'on a vécu
depuis 3 ans peuvent se répéter dans les
mois et les années à venir merci merci
beaucoup Denis d'avoir été avec nous la
une Denis ce matin vous en avez parlé
les réponses de Christian Estrosi après
la tempête àine et puis votre dossier du
jour sur la fin des voitures pas chères
merci beaucoup Donis Caro d'avoir été
avec nous on va passer au premier débat
de ce club on va parler de Gérald
hararmanin Alex gerérald haranin qui
hier dans le JDD a continué d'envoyer
des signau à la droite pour faire
adopter sa loi
oui des signaux à droite d'abord par le
choix du journal dans lequel il
s'exprime c'est la première fois qu'un
ministre de son rang faisait la une du
Journal du Dimanche depuis que jefrois
le jeune ancien directeur de valeurs
actuelles en a pris la tête cet été le
ministre de l'Intérieur Géral le
dararmanin a accordé une interview fleu
sur trois pages pleines pour expliquer
l'intégralité de son projet de loi
immigration qui sera débattu au Sénat
début novembre et il ne manque pas de
qualificatif pour faire l'éloge de son
texte je le cite c'est le texte le plus
ferme avec les mesures les plus dures
depuis ces 30 dernières années il assure
je cite qu'il n'y a aucune question
tabou si c'est pour être efficace pour
protéger les Français le ministre qui
poursuit son discours de fermeté
vis-à-vis de la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme la CEDH qui aimit
souvent des recours contre l'expulsion
de certains étrangers en France c'est
une une institution qui est très
critiquée par la droite de la classe
politique je cite gerérard learmmanin la
CEDH doit comprendre qu'elle juge dans
une situation de crise terroriste qui
n'existait pas lorsque ces règles fut
imaginées et géralmanin qui a évoqué
également le fameux article 3 du projet
de loi sur la régularisation des
travailleurs sans papier article dont ne
veulent pas les républicains oui on le
rappelle le gouvernement a besoin du
vote des républicain pour faire adopter
son projet de loi immigration à
l'Assemblée nationale mais les LR sont
vend debout contre cet article 3 qui
régularise les travailleurs sans papier
dans les métiers en tension article 3
auquel est attaché une partie la
majorité présidentielle l'aile gauche de
la majorité présidentielle d'où se
casse-tête pour géralde dararmanin et on
sent que le ministre de l'Intérieur en a
un peu marre de ce débat qui dure depuis
des mois autour de cette mesure qui est
selon lui pas la plus importante
notamment dans le contexte terroriste je
cite le ministre l'heure et cependant
assez grave pour qu'on ait des compromis
sur des choses qui ne sont pas centrales
autrement dit on est en train de couper
les cheveux en qu pour pas grand-chose
certains veulent un décret ou une
circulaire d'autres que ce soit dans la
loi nous discuterons donc de ce sujet
mais le gouvernement est attaché à des
mesures de justice envers ceux qui
produisent dans notre pays sans jamais
poser de problèmes d'ordre public donc
Géral Darmanin a beau montrer les
muscles envoyé des signaux à la droite
il n'a toujours pas décidé d'abandonner
ce principe de la régularisation des
travailleurs sans papier Mathieu souker
il pousse encore plus loin le curseur
Gérald amanin pour tenter de convaincre
la droite sur cette loi immigration oui
alors par ailleurs il illustre assez
bien en fait le déport du macronisme au
fil du temps vers la droite et même vers
une droite de plus en plus assumée vous
rappeliez en fait que de façon
symbolique il était donc celui qui parmi
les ministres importants était le
premier à concéder une une interview au
JDD ce qui n'est évidemment pas nôtre
alors le le le en même temps est
toujours difficile à faire valoir au au
pouvoir et on sait que même les
gouvernements de gauche ont eu tendance
à se déporter euh face à une forme de
réalisme politique vers le centre ou
vers la droite en dans l'exercice des
responsabilités mais là on voit bien que
géralde daranin va sans doute plus loin
alors il y a cette il y a cette capacité
même cette volonté probablement à
alimenter des polémiques récurrentes en
mode il n'y a pas de tabou en politique
et je suis celui qui parle vrai y
compris quand ça dérange de ce point de
vue-là il y a une petite filiation parmi
d'autres avec avec Nicolas Sarkozi donc
il y a parfois cette outrance là mais je
dirais que au-delà de l'outrance ouou ou
de l'excès il y a parfois aussi cette
forme de plasticité politique du
macronisme qui fait que on peut au
moment d'une élection présidentielle par
exemple dire nous sommes le rempart
contre l'extrême droite et quelques
semaines ou quelques mois après dire
Marine Le Pen est molle insruire le
procès en molaisse de Marine Le Pen et
dire c'est nous qui pour de vrai sur les
questions identitaires ou sur les
questions sécuritaire incarnons une
forme de sérieux et d'ordre plasticité
c'est c'est quoi c'est le mot sympa pour
dire qu'il y a pas de corpusé éologique
en tout cas c'est le mot sympa pour dire
que au gré des circonstances
effectivement on peut dire parfois
presque tout est son contraire
suranmanin il tréard il pousse les
curseurs à droite est-ce qu'il les
poussent trop loin est-ce qu'il en fait
trop le ministre de l'Intérieur bah on
le SAA plus tard si vous voulez c'est
vrai qu'il s'agite beaucoup il parle
beaucoup il il fait des choses qui
d'ailleurs qui sont à mon avis
contreproductives et qui peuvent être
dangereuses pour pour i comme cette
histoire de polémique avec Karim Benzema
en vraiment en s'égarant sur un sujet
qu'il maîtrise pas parce que il porte
une accusation qui est si elle est
fondée elle est fondée mais si elle
n'est pas fondée c'est grave quand même
surtout qu'il est ministre de
l'Intérieur il est pas battlerur à
l'estrade de l'Assemblée nationale c'est
c'est quand même un peu grave je trouve
et donc il faut qu'il trouve le juste
ton là c'est pareil il va au JDD bah
très bien le JDD est un journal comme
l'un autre contrairement à ce que tout
le monde dit euh je vois pas très bien
la différence euh mais
euh il prend trois pages il prend trois
pages et il fait du en même temps en
fait effectivement on sent que depuis
euh euh pas mal de temps bah euh Gérard
Amarin a besoin et veut absolument
conquérir les voix de droite de la
droite républicaine et donc ça fait un
moment qu'il parle il parle il parle il
parle beaucoup pour montrer euh et pour
euh je dirais donner une tonalité de
fermeté euh à l'opinion publique mais ce
qui va compter au bout du compte c'est
est-ce qu'il y a un vote ou pas euh
est-ce que la loi qu'il propose alors il
y a l'article 3 effectivement qui a été
euh détaillé tout à l'heure savoir quel
avenir pour cet article mais sur le
reste si vous voulez c'est euh est-ce
que c'est est-ce que est-ce que cette
loi va pouvoir être adoptée
euh c'est toute la question avec ou 1493
euh avec l'accord d'une partie de la
droite sans diviser la majorité parce
que la majorité on le sent est assez
fragile et précaire sur ce sur ce frontl
donc on SAA plus tard moi c'est c'est
c'est à ça que je jugerai si vous voulez
après oui géralman qui est à la
recherche d'une majorité il rir dans le
Journal du Dimanche tous ces textes ont
été adoptés 1493 est-ce que là les
affaires se compliquent alors assurément
contte tenu du contexte politique qui
est le nôtre Gérald armanin fait le le
Paris d'être l'héritier du macronisme et
de pouvoir être potentiellement le
candidat de la majorité présidentielle
dans dans 4 ans d'être l'héritier du
macronisme en étant en réalité
l'héritier du sarkozisme parce que c'est
quand même avec cette histoire là que
son identité politique tâche de renouer
un une très grande fermeté sur les
questions régaliennes et deux une fibre
sociale qui fait écho à ce que disait
Nicolas Sarkozi en 2007 identité
nationale d'un côté pouvoir d'achat de
l'autre avec le fameux travailler plus
pour gagner plus donc c'est ça
précisément en fait le le sillon que
tente aujourd'hui de creuser géralde
Darmanin encore une fois on est dans une
équation politique très différente de ce
que pouvait être la situation d' a il y
a une quinzaine d'années alors avec le
calcul quand même que l'opinion s'est
droitisée que même une partie de la
droite c'est extrême droitisée et que
pour franchir le mur du son et pour être
politiquement audible il faut en réalité
pousser les curseurs le plus loin
possible voilà mais encore une fois ça
correspond pour partie à des attentes de
l'opinion dont une partie effectivement
c'est droitisé mais on est dans un
contexte aussi où la la demande de de
tempérance la demande d'écoute la
demande de nuance et de plus en plus
grande il y avait par exemple en 2017
une très forte demande de radicalité
dans le paysage dans l'opinion publique
qu'une Marine Le Pen ou qu'un un
Jean-Luc Mélenchon avait tenté de capter
on n plus exactement en fait dans la
même histoire aujourd'hui et donc le le
voilà les les les propos radicaux que ce
soit parfois chez la France insoumise ou
de l'autre côté avec éc Zemour on a vu
en particulier que ces derniers mois ça
ça ça ne recueillait plus le même écho
positif qu'auparavant donc la stratégie
de géralanin n'est pas forcément la
bonne euh elle elle est ass sur ment
risqué considère qu'elle est assurément
risqué en tout cas elle n'est pas une
garantie de résultat en la matière en
particulier parce que le partenaire de
droite celui qui aurait dû être le
partenaire légitime depuis un an en fait
n'assume pas ce positionnement là
considérant que sa survie politique
précisément passe par une opposition
avec la majorité présidentielle alors
que sur le fond objectivement on avait
compris quand même que alors que
Emmanuel Macron s'était fait élire par
les voies de centre-gauche en 2017 il
s'est clairement clairement fait réélir
en 2022 par les voies de droite en ayant
siphoné le programme et l'électorat de
de Valérie PC alors il y a une chose qui
est quand même très importante hein que
dans le contexte actuel et qui un
contexte quand même assez anxiogène avec
une demande quand même d'une majorité de
la population de sécurité de protection
tout ça si jamais cette loi ce projet de
loi n'est pas adopté c'est une
catastrophe pour la majorité c'est une
catastrophe pour le président de la
République il a pas il a pas le droit de
se représenter d'accord mais d'abord ça
porte un coup quand même même à son
autorité pour la fin de son quinquéa et
deuxièmement ça dit rien de bon pour
ceux qui veulent et qui voudrai lui
succéder dans cet axe central euh qui
est euh qui est assez flou d'ailleurs
euh et pour ceux qui au gouvernement
songe à à lui succéder comme Darmanin
comme le maire comme d'autres ça serait
vraiment une gifle euh et une gifle qui
serait évidemment très profitable à
beaucoup d'autres et notamment à Marine
Le Pen ça tient aussi au fait que Gérald
d'Anin aurait dû être l'homme fort de
cette rentrée ou prétendait être l'homme
fort de cette rentrée alors les choses
sont en réalité un peu plus compliquées
alors d'abord parce que son bilan de
ministre de l'Intérieur au cours des
derniers mois n'a pas été si brillant
que cela toujours en matière de maintien
de l'ordre on se souvient en particulier
d'une finale de football qui avait
considérablement dégénéré et qui fait
que aujourd'hui dans les enquêtes
d'opinion une majorité de Français
s'inquiète précisément des questions de
sécurité au moment de l'organisation des
Jos donc on voit bien que la maison ne
semble pas aux yeux de tout le monde du
plus grand nombre parfaitement tenu de
de ce point de vuelà donc et et même je
dirais que il y a un contraste assez
saisissant entre cette rentrée dans en
cette rentrée entre la façon dont Gérald
armanin était censé occuper le terrain
avec une rentrée politique une réunion
politique qui a été en fait totalement
fagocitée par ellisabeth born quoi qu'on
pense d'Élisabeth borne ça n'est pas un
grand animal politique et pourtant elle
est venue en en quelques minutes de
discours torpiller la rentrée politique
de Gérald armanin là où à l'inverse un
Gabriel Atal par exemple semble sur faer
une vague extrêmement favorable depuis
quelques semaines donc le le Géral en
tout cas pas dans la séquence l'homme
ultra fort du gouvernement comme il
prétend comme il prétend des
lettres ça
volontéab ça c'est clair d'ù sa volonté
de s'afficher d'être sur tous les fronts
oui alors non mais depuis le début de
tout manière mais le problème si vous
voulez c'est qu'il est sur des fronts
qui sont des fronts délicats Gabriel
Atal aussi mais Gabriel Atal ce qui est
intéressant c'est que Gérald armanin a
été retenu par la première ministre qui
a essayé de de de de lui compliquer un
peu la tâche et que Gabriel hatal au
début souvenez-vous de ce qu'on disait
on disait finalement le président de la
République va vouloir être lui-même le
ministre de l'Éducation il va pas
laisser de place à Gabriel Attal Gabriel
Attal a réussi à trouver une ouverture
euh notamment avec la la la la la baaya
si vous voulez l'interdiction de la
baaya dans les écoles qui qui de
requérait pas de loi rien simplement une
une circulaire il a réussi à s'imposer
là-dessus et puis à faire deux ou trois
apparitions médiatiques qui je crois ont
porté et euh et voilà donc le le la
Gabriel Atal a réussi à se faire une
place quand même euh Gabriel pour une
raison simple c'est qu'atal Atal a
cherché des points de consensus en
réalité sur la baaya sur l'uniforme sur
les savoirs fondamentaux et cetera là où
précisément Gérald harmanin fait le
choix tactique inverse d'être sur des
sujets cvant de parler d'écoterrorisme
de parler de la CEDH en des termes qui
effectivement questionnent à tout le
moins d'aller sur les terres du
rassemblement national donc précisément
on n'est pas du tout le même ch mais
est-ce que sur un texte comme
l'immigration il peut rassembler est-ce
qu'il paye pas ce que vous appeliez tout
à l'heure la plasticité à savoir qu'on a
un texte en même temps un peu de droite
un peu de gauche et du coup c'est
difficile de tout concilier dans un même
texte oui j'y ajouterai même une forme
de responsabilité il y a la tentation
quand même de porter cette question
migratoire de façon clivante alors même
que précisément nous aurions besoin de
l'aborder de façon la plus rationnelle
la plus nuancée et la plus documenté
possible on voit bien que la classe
politique a sur ce sujet-l en réalité du
mal à faire preuve d'esprit de
responsabilité et de tempérance encore
une fois sur la question migratoire qui
désormais dans la bouche de de de plus
en plus nombreux leaders politiques est
confondu avec la question identitaire et
la question sécuritaire nos grands
démographes ou nos grands spécialistes
du sujet ne parlent pas de subversion
migratoire au contraire je je pense à
François erand ou à Hervé Lebras les uns
et les autres en fait appellent à une
forme de mise en perspective en
considérant que sur la question
migratoire on est loin d'un certain
nombre de nos partenaires Allemagne en
tête voilà il n'y a pas de subversion
migratoire et pourtant il y a un débat
politique un débat public qui est
largement pollué par un certain nombre
de de de si ce n'est de fantasme en tout
cas d'instrumentalisation de préjugés
donc pour vous le contexte actuel ne
pousse pas pousse pas forcément Gérald
haranin à à plus de fermeté c'est son
choix il y aurait eu quelque chose de
tout à fait responsable à dire nous
avons un débat sur l'immigration et nous
adoptons une nouvelle loi sur
l'immigration après par exemple une
convention citoyenne sur le sujet c'est
la capacité que nous donnerion à
l'opinion publique dans son ensemble de
s'en saisir de la façon la plus
rationnelle et la plus documentée
possible
oui sauf que le débat politique n'est
jamais
rationnel un débat politique n'est
jamais rationnel et je crois que les
démographes peent dire ce qu'ils veulent
l'opinion
publique ne peut pas aujourd'hui me
semble-t-il n'est pas dans une humeur
tel qu'elle peut suivre ces démograp là
le discours sur on a besoin
d'immigration ne passe pas ça ne peut
pas passer et c'est normal d'ailleurs
parce que le curseur il est pas là et le
débat il est pas là-dessus il est pas SR
on a besoin d'immigration pas du tout il
est et et et et l'actualité le montre il
est sur la crainte de nombreux Français
de se voir déposséder culturellement des
valeurs et des piliers de leur pays il
est là le sujet il est pas de savoir
s'il faut de les immigrer c'est pas le
sujet ça on est plus 1980 on n plus euh
on n'est plus du tout dans ce contexte
là on est dans le contexte où euh il y a
l'histoire de la il y a eu l'histoire de
de de du voile à l'école il y a eu
l'histoire de la BAA il y a eu
l'histoire de ce de ce que Gilles kpel
appelle le le djihadisme d'atmosphère
c'est-à-dire une espèce d'entrrisme
culturel euh de de de l'islam en France
qui se double en plus d'acte assassin
comme on a pu le voir
euh avec grande surprise quand même on
pensait pas que ça serait aussi rapide
après ce qui s'est passé au Proche
Orient qui est un un attentat et un
meurtre et un assassinat de la sorte
donc je pense qu'il est là le sujet et
tout le monde se rend compte et c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon à l'intérieur même de son
parti est contesté on va en parler c'est
quand même une c'est une première parce
que l'islamogauchisme qui était peu
importe la formule l'islam gauchisme qui
était reproché à à la France insoumise
qui ne qui qui qui manifestait tout à
fait ouvertement pour défendre les
femmes voilées il y a en 2019 au mois de
novembre 2019 aujourd'hui la même
estation n'a plus le même écho dans son
à l'intérieur même du parti ça veut dire
qu'il y en a bien quelquesuns beaucoup
même qui sentent que il font fausse
route on va y venir justement à Jean-Luc
Mélenchon Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui a
publié un tweet très controversé hier en
réaction à la visite au déplacement de
yel brun pivé en Israël madame brun pivé
campe à tel avive pour encourager le
massacre on va écouter ce matin la
réaction de y brun PIV elle était
l'invité de la matinale de France Inter
connaissant un peu Jean-Luc mé
je suis convaincue qu'effectivement le
mot camper n'a pas été choisi par hasard
et que le fait que je favorise les
massacres
c'est à nouveau une nouvelle cible qu'on
me met dans le dos je suis désolé mais
je
suis je suis très choquée en fait je
suis navraée voilà on sent l'émotion la
forte émotion
ditelbonelleut êre tromée elle peut être
trée peutêtre elle peut être émue parce
que c'est odieux ce qu'il a dit c'est
auieux ce qu'il a raconté
auieux vous avez oublié de signifier que
Madame BR Pivet a des origines juives
c'est odieux ce qu'il a
dit il est actuellement dans un Paris
que j'ai appelé dans l'éditorial du
Figaro ce matin dans un Paris honteux et
extrêmement dangereux extrêmement
dangereux il fait le Paris d'aller
gagner un
électorat sensible aux questions à la
question islamique euh qu'il a gagné en
partie d'ailleurs à l'occasion des
élections législatives et de l'élection
présidentielle de
2020 2 et il fait le Paris que il y a
encore beaucoup d'absentionistes et ces
absentionnistes partagent ces mêmes
opinionsl
euh sur un plan purement statistique et
arithmétique il a peut-être pas tort
hein mais sur le fond HM c'est quelque
chose qui est absolument abject il nous
fait exactement ce qui était reproché à
Jean-Marie Le Pen il y a 30 ans on va on
va revenir là-dessus juste la phrase de
y Bron Pivet qui est qui est très forte
hein qui accuse Jean-Luc Mélenchon de
lui mettre une cible dans le dos bah en
même temps on voit bien quand même les
réactions suscitées par le par le tweet
de Jean-Luc pélenchon hier c'estàdire
que depuis 10 jours ou 15 jours on a une
classe politique qui est de façon
unanime dit attention à ne pas importer
sur notre sol ce qui se passe au Proche
Orient donc soyons tous colle
effectivement le plus responsable
possible et à la hauteur de l'événement
on voit bien que précisément une
déclaration comme celle-ci met de
l'huile sur le feu dans un pays la
France où la communauté juive est la
plus importante d'Europe et où
précisément la communauté musulmane
elle-même est aussi la plus importante
d'Europe donc on peut avoir sur notre
sol à l'ône d'une telle actualité
internationale un certain nombre de
friction de tension et même de violence
donc le rôle de la classe politique
précisément est d'apaiser d'apaiser et
de donner du sens à la séquence parce
que la séquence est complexe donc
précisément ce qu'on doit avoir c'est un
débat politique un débat public qui là
encore une fois est responsable et
serein alors on voit bien que si on dit
souvent que on doit protéger nos enfants
des réseaux sociaux et des dégâts des
réseaux sociaux là on a vraiment le
sentiment que c'est la classe politique
dans son ensemble qu'il faut protéger
des réseaux sociaux comment une
déclaration de cette nature en fait peut
produire de tels résultats et on arrive
effectivement à ce que il trard
qualifiait de de de front renversé
c'estàdire queon on a Jean-Luc Mélenchon
dont je rappelle qu'il était par exemple
ministre dionel Jospin en 2002 jusqu'en
2002 on a Jean-Luc Jean-Luc Mélenchon
qui aujourd'hui capte insidieusement une
critique en antisémitisme là où de
l'autre côté de les chiquiers politiques
on a aujourd'hui une extrême droite qui
est passée précisément de
l'antisémitisme de Jean-Marie Le Pen un
antisémitisme de calambourg mais qui
était un antisémitisme organique on est
passé de ça à un soutien inconditionnel
à Israël et on a du coup une extrême
droite qui fait la leçon à une partie de
la gauche bien sûr qu'il y a toujours eu
une part d'antisémitisme et
d'antisionisme à gauche mais
historiquement tout à fait résiduel
existant mais tout à fait résiduel
l'antisémitisme il était évidemment
organiquement d'extrême droite on en est
plus là on a une Marine Le Pen qui du
coup se permet de faire la leçon à
l'ensemble de la classe politique sur ce
sujet-là pardon avec là encore l'aide
alors il y a sa stratégie à elle de
dédiabolisation depuis une nombreuses
années là encore avec le renfort
incongru et inattendu d'Éric Zemour qui
est quand même celui qui depuis un an
incarne la figure du Juif péténiste ou
du Juif qui réhabilite voire même admire
Philippe Pétin ouais mais pour aller
dans le sens de ce que vous dites on
avait Jean-Philippe Tangui qui était
notre invité le président délégué du
groupe rassemblement national à
l'assemblée qui accusa Jean-Luc
Mélenchon il y a quelques minutes de
faire de l'antisémitisme d'atmosphère hm
hm oui bah c'est une expression
effectivement qui est qui est grave hein
quand même
euh mais on peut l'interpréter comme ça
parce que c'est vrai que en plus le
choix du vocabulaire madame Bron Pivet a
relevé l'usage du mot quand euh on voit
très bien à quoi fait référence
évidemment malheureusement et tristement
mais pour vous aussi l' pas choisi au
hasard ce mot pas qu' vous savez avec
Mélenchon rien n'est au hasardin jean
Mélenchon abo est un tribunicien qui
s'emporte qu' des emportements mais ce
sont souvent des emportements qui sont
calculés qui sont réfléchis il'est pas à
l'abri d'une énorme bour de oui c'est
vrai comme d'ailleurs tout le monde hein
personne mais c'est vrai que là c'est
quand même assez incroyable quoi ouais
incroable il persiste d'ailleurs aussi à
considérer que le ramas n'est pas un
mouvement terroriste alors que que il
est inscrit justement sur tous les
fichiers comme un mouvement terroriste
la question c'est jusqu'où va la
stratégie de conflictualisation en fait
même pas seulement de la France
insoumise quand même en fait de Jean-Luc
méenchant lui-même là pour le coup il y
a une dérive qui paraît être une dérive
individuelle on avait déjà aborderé la
semaine dernière quand même le fait que
pour la première fois émergit des
divisions explicites au sein de la
France insoumise avec une une minorité
de plus en plus importante parmi ceux
qui contestent et les propos de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et le fonctionnement
démocratique adémocratique
antidémocratique du mouvement en réalité
ça ça monte et encore une fois moi je ne
suis pas sûr que tout ça ne finisse pas
par s'accumuler sous forme de sparadra
et de sparadra indécollable quand même
pour Jean-Luc mélencha mais est-ce que
là il est en train de chercher la
diabolisation lui à contrario je je
encore une fois s'agit-il d'une
stratégie de de conflictualisation
poussée jusqu'au bout en faisant le
calcul qu'elle paye ou s'agit-il quand
même d'une forme de dérive que y compris
l'entourage proche de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
pourrait questionner je je je ne sais
pas répondre à ça en fait et ça pose la
question de la diabolisation mais ça
pose aussi la question de la gauche des
conséquences à gauche c'est ce que vous
traitez aujourd'hui dans les colonnes du
Figaro cette gauche qui prépare
l'aprèsmélenchon est-ce qu'avec cette
déclaration elle y est encore plus
contrainte à préparer l'près Mélenchon
ah bah oui logiquement ceux qui ne
veulent pas partager la route de
Mélenchon et justement ce pas
de aller plus loin je dirais dans dans
le sens de Mélenchon ils vont essayer de
s'organiser le problème de cette de de
ceux qui ne veulent pas suivre Mélenchon
c'est qu'il y a un problème un de
leadership
qui et de de ligne programmatique aussi
parce que on va pas se cacher le on va
pas pas se voliler la face pourquoi ceux
qui à gauche depuis le début ne veulent
pas suivre Jean-Luc Mélenchon n'arrivent
pas à émerger c'est madame delgard
madamealgo monsieur
casneu il se rassemble
il s'exprime y compris dans les médias
mais ils sont ils sont pas audibles
enfin je veux dire ça ça bouge pas ça ça
marche pas com François Hollande
François Hollande pareil alors il y a le
côté usure du pouvoir pour François
Hollande en tous les cas ça c'est
manifeste et puis le fait qu'il est pas
vraiment brillé à l'Élysée ça c'est la
première des choses mais il y a une
deuxième chose c'est qu'il y a beaucoup
beaucoup d'électeurs de cette
socialdémocratie qui est parti chez chez
Emmanuel Macron alors même en dépit de
la droitisation
du discours de de Monsieur Macron et
bien ils sont restés là vous le voyez he
il y en a il y en a quand même beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup et donc c'est pour ça
qu'aussi Jean-Luc mélenchan avait choisi
cette ce
raiddissement qui d'ailleurs lui va
assez bien au teint on va pas le cacher
mais est-ce qu'il y a un espace encore
aujourd'hui justement pour une social
démocratie enfin à une gauche de
gouvernement tout comme d'ailleurs il y
a-t-il un espace on le voit à droite
entre Marine Le Pen avec une forme de
populisme qui est le sien et Jean-Luc
méange et Emmanuel Macron VO bien que
les LR ont bien du mal à se faire à se
faire une place au soleil Mathie souer
est-ce que pour vous la gauche est en
capacité de passer à l'après Mélenchon
alors ces espaces politiques à gauche
comme à droite existent en réalité mais
ça ils existe tout à fait je pense que à
gauche comme à droite il y a eu un
travail insuffisant en matière
d'inventaire de ce qui a été fait ou pas
fait quand la gauche était au pouvoir
mais ça vaudrait aussi pour la droite
républicaine et et par ailleurs aucun
travail programmatique pour la suite je
pense que ce sont effectivement des
partis politiques qui sont morts de ne
pas avoir suffisamment travaillé et
suffisamment travaillé sur eux-même mais
par ailleurs au-delà en fait de la
division que ça introduit une nouvelle
fois à gauche je pense que ce qui se
passe autour de Mélenchon est est plus
large et plus grave que ça là par
exemple on doit avoir cet après-midi un
débat à l'Assemblée nationale sur la
situation au Proche Orient et on voit
bien que po par un certain nombre de
considérations politiciennes ce débat
risque de ne pas être à la hauteur de ce
qu'il devrait être comme disait Ruffin
la semaine dernière de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon on n'est pas à la hauteur en
fait du moment et c'est je dirais la
classe politique dans son ensemble ou à
peu près qui n'est pas à la hauteur de
du de l'événement
depuis quelques jours sur le conflit
israëlo-palestinien n'est pas non plus à
la hauteur de l'événement le soutien
inconditionnel à Israël et la
proposition de supprimer les aides au
développement le soutien de l'Union
européenne à la Palestine et cetera
n'est pas non plus à la hauteur de
l'événement on ne punit pas un peuple à
l'Ô précisément d'un acte terroriste
particulier donc et et et avec ce que je
vous disais de l'extrême droite
elle-même qui est à front renversé on
voit bien que on est collectivement
totalement déboussolé et on suivra
évidemment ce débat à l'Assemblée cet
après-midi on en reparlera demain
d'abord on regarde qu'elle a une de nos
quotidiens
[Musique]
régionaux et Alex on commence par
l'évacuation de laazade contre le projet
d'autoroute à 69 oui c'est à la Une de
l'édition du T de la Dépêche du Midi la
Zade installée à se contre la
construction de cette autoroute entre
Toulouse et castre a été évacué par les
forces de l'ordre hier après-midi après
un weekend de forte tension quelques
policiers ont été légèrement blessés et
dans ce contexte le journal Le Midi
Libre propose un dossier sur tous les
projet les projets de route qui sont la
cible de violente opposition en
Occitanie comme l'autoroute à 69 des
projets parmi lesquels le contournement
routier de Montpellier de nîes et
d'Arles qui sont contesté par des
associations de défense de
l'environnement réunie dans un collectif
baptisé la déroute des routes un
collectif qui demande je cite une
suspension de tous les projets
destructeurs alors le ministre des
Transports Clément bonne a dit que le
projet d'autoroute à 69 ira jusqu'au
bout mais que certains autres projets
seront annulés et sans doute ce sera le
cas du contournement de la ville d'Arles
qui selon ses opposant mettra en danger
la biodiversité de la Camargue on a vu
Alex la Une de La Dépêche dans son
édition du tard mais dans ces les autres
éditions il les question d'un scandale
sur les moteurs d'avion et oui le
scandale des pièces étachées de moteurs
d'avion des pièces qui ont été vendues
avec des faux certificats par une
entreprise britannique qui est dans le
viseur de la justice un trafic de pièces
qui concerne au moins une centaine de
moteurs d'avion mis en circulation alors
quelle peuvent être les conséquences
cela peut entraîner une baisse
d'efficacité des moteurs des pannes mais
pas des accidents vraisemblablement des
accidents qui ne sont pas envisagés pour
l'instant car en cas de
dysfonctionnement il faut le rappeler un
avion est capable de voler avec un seul
moteur pendant euh plusieurs heures
plusieurs heures donc pas de panique
Orian à la Une de l'Est républiain les
Français restent fans de l'eau en
bouteille oui 47 % des Français restent
accro à l'eau en bouteille et affirme en
boire tous les jours 74 % des Français
se disent être des buveurs mixes
c'est-à-dire un peu d'eau en bouteille
un peu d'eau du robinet hein ce sont les
chiffres du centre de l'information de
l'eau cela fait chaque jour 36 millions
de bouteilles plastiques d'eau qui sont
consommé en France et les défenseurs de
l'environnement déplorent avec cette
consommation la surexploitation des na
fréatique et à l'abération écologique
des déchets plastiques que cela génère
termine par du foot oui on finit par
quelques une de la presse régionale sur
la Ligue 1 le foot avec une nouvelle
défaite de l'Olympique Lyonnais 2-1
contre Clermont c'est affligeant à la
une du Progrès de Lyon puisque l'OL est
dernier du championnat et c'est une
délivrance pour les auvernias les
Clermontois qui remportent leur première
victoire de la saison c'est à la Une du
journal La Montagne merci Alex on
regarde la Une du Figaro on en a parlé
if cette gauche qui prépare l'après
Mélenchon c'est à lire aujourd'hui dans
le Figaro et Mathieu soucler on revoit
votre livre 2022 la flambée populiste
sécher plomb merci à tous les deux
d'avoir été avec nous merci Alex merci à
tous de nous avoir suivi à 18h vous avez
rendez-v avec Thomas H pour sens public
et nous on ça sera 22h d'ailleurs
puisque'à 16h vous suivrez le débat à
l'Assemblée nationale et nous on se
retrouve
demain